let's go to our caller from the four one
three area code the old stomping ground
of the David Pakman show who's calling
today from four one three hello yes you
hear me yes hi this is Mike Kim from
Western Mass hey Mike what's up so I
just have some questions about your
position on health care okay so a lot of
the progressive media has been saying
that you know qyt or secular talk or
other media have been saying that
Bernie's Medicare for all Persian
Bernie's version is the populist
position but if you look at the polls
it's actually the Medicare for all who
wanted or but the public option which is
the popular position sorry did you get
cut offer with it was there a question
there yeah sorry yeah I got cut off so
my question is what's your position on
what's your position on Medicare for all
specific specifically Bernie's position
because according to the polls the
Popular's position is Medicare for all
who wanted the public option I don't
know what what are you according to the
polls what does that mean according to
the polls the popular popular or
populous I'm having a really hard time
understanding what you're saying okay
pop folk well I guess popular position
is public option okay I've not seen
those polls and the polls have nothing
to do with what I think would be best so
here's the deal the public option is a
milquetoast half measure the the best
studies I've seen say that if you pass a
public option it will reduce premiums by
about 7 percent and of course premiums
often go up by 10 percent every year so
it would basically save part of one
year's increase in premiums it's a very
milquetoast half measure it doesn't
really fix the problems we have Medicare
for all fixes lots of the problems that
we have there are
some if no plan is perfect there are
some issues with medicare-for-all one of
them being that the the best studies
i've seen say in order to really deliver
the care quality level at the
accessibility level that Bernie wants
that it's simply going to cost way more
than he says that might still be okay
right like we might say it'll cost way
more but that's okay
but yeah I mean it's the polls you're
citing I haven't seen them I don't know
anything about that okay so let's say
that hypothetically because you didn't
see it let's say that it is a public
option is the most popular position yeah
among the general population but you
still want to push for Bernie's version
of Medicare for all
so my view on this is not informed by
what people like I mean listen sixty
something million people voted for
Donald Trump it happened to be fewer
than the number that voted for Hillary
but like I don't really care about it
being popular or unpopular my view is
what do the studies say about how to
deliver the best care most effectively
to the most number of people and the
public option is just it's just a half
measure and it won't do very much oh
okay all right thanks for the answer I
appreciate that
all right Mike great to hear from you
always great to hear from folks in in in
western Massachusetts